Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je vous propose pour commencer
de regarder cette image
que vous avez probablement déjà vue.
C’est une vieille image du 19ᵉ siècle.
Elle a beaucoup circulé,
elle a circulé dans des manuels scolaires,
elle a circulé dans des livres.
Et vous la trouvez sur Wikipedia,
par exemple.
Cette image,
c’est celle d’Abraham Lincoln,
16ᵉ Président des États-Unis,
dans une pose très hiératique,
très formelle.
Sur les documents à côté de lui,
il y a ses réalisations.
Et on s’attend à ce qu’il nous déclame
un grand discours.
Par contre, cette image-là,
vous la connaissez peut-être moins.
C'est celle de John Calhoun.
C’est le septième vice-président
des États-Unis,
donc un peu avant Lincoln.
C’est une image qui a été produite en 1852
à partir d’une photo qui a été
retravaillée en sérigraphie.
Et cette image, c'est l'originale.
Entre ces deux images,
il y a évidemment une manipulation,
manipulation typique -
à l’époque, c’est purement graphique,
on a dessiné la tête de Lincoln
sur le corps de Calhoun -
mais c’est absolument caractéristique
de toutes les manipulations
qui ont existé dans le passé
et qui existent toujours de nos jours.
Faisons un petit bond dans le temps.
On est en 1950.
Déclaration de Robert Schumann,
qui est considérée
comme la fondation de l’Europe.
C’est le premier traité
signé franco-allemand
qui va créer les échanges
à la base de l’Europe.
Cette déclaration a lieu le 9 mai 1950.
Malheureusement, il n’y a ni journalistes
ni photographes dans la salle.
Et pour résoudre ce problème-là, en juin,
tout le monde est convié à nouveau.
Tout le monde va revenir prendre
la pose pour une jolie photo.
Alors cette photo, évidemment,
est décalée dans le temps.
Et les photographes font
une petite erreur à ce moment-là.
Ils la font à un moment
qui n’est pas le moment de la signature,
pas la même heure que celle
où avait été signée la déclaration.
Problème : ils ont fait le choix
de faire cette déclaration
dans le salon de l’Horloge,
qui est caractérisé par… une horloge.
Et cette horloge-là devrait
avoir des aiguilles.
Évidemment, quand on s’est rendu compte
qu’il y avait un problème à ce niveau-là,
on a effacé les aiguilles.
Les photographes ont manipulé l’image
et ont effacé ces aiguilles gênantes.
Alors, dans cette image-là,
il n’y a pas de volonté malicieuse,
il n’y a pas une volonté
de tromper les gens.
On a simplement voulu s’éviter
une troisième photographie,
reconvoquer les gens
une troisième fois pour rien.
Il n’empêche que dans tous les manuels
d’histoire et sur Wikipédia encore,
dans ce qui est en rapport
avec la fondation de l’Europe,
vous aurez cette photo
et c’est une photo manipulée.
On voit de plus en plus
d’éléments comme ça.
Si vous voyez cette personne,
elle vous dit quelque chose, probablement.
Elle ressemble à quelqu'un
que vous connaissez.
Peut-être qu’elle ressemble à Brad Pitt.
Oui, mais il ressemble aussi à Tom Cruise.
Ça s’appelle un morphing,
c’est une image intermédiaire
créée par une fusion
entre les caractéristiques biométriques
des deux personnes.
C’est un élément qui est, en lui-même,
une manipulation assez simple
qui semble un peu neutre comme ça,
oui, mais on peut en faire
des choses très dangereuses,
comme par exemple
ce qu’on appelle le Magic Passport.
Ça consiste à faire entre deux personnes
qui se ressemblent un petit peu,
peut-être pas à ce point-là, quand même,
des personnes un peu plus proches,
de faire une déclaration d’identité
sur l’une de ces deux personnes
et d’amener une photo
qui ressemble à cette personne,
mais qui ressemble aussi
à une autre personne.
Magic Passport permet de faire passer
deux personnes sur le même document
avec une seule identité.
Évidemment, là, on entre sur des pratiques
qui sont un peu plus proches de la mafia.
Le morphing existe depuis très longtemps.
Je le connaissais techniquement
depuis au moins le générique de Thalassa
sur France 3 dans les années 80.
On a beaucoup modernisé ces technologies.
Une avancée décisive en la matière
a été faite en 2014 par Ian Goodfellow
avec une technologie qui sert
à beaucoup d’autres choses,
qui s’appelle les GANs,
Generative Adversarial Networks.
Les GANs, c’est simplement
deux réseaux de neurones artificiels
qui travaillent l’un contre l’autre.
L’un apprend à fabriquer
dans ce cas précis, une fausse photo
et l’autre apprend à détecter
si une photo ou pas.
Et au fur et à mesure,
ils vont se renforcer l’un l’autre.
Celui qui fait des fausses photos va faire
des photos de plus en plus fausses,
de plus en plus crédibles,
et celui qui détecte va détecter
de mieux en mieux.
Et c’est comme ça qu’on arrive,
avec beaucoup d’améliorations,
en 2019, sur la photo de droite.
C’est ce qu’on appelle du Stein-GAN 2.
Techniquement,
c’est le même type de chose.
La photo de droite est assez crédible.
J’ai un petit problème parce qu’en fait,
ce n’est pas la bonne image.
Je vais rester sur cette image-là.
Normalement, une autre image
aurait dû apparaître à l’écran.
Cette image, c'est celle
de Monsieur Bondarenko.
Ce monsieur est apparu
il y a quelques jours,
sur Twitter et Facebook,
il se présente comme ukrainien
et il a, disons, beaucoup de choses
à reprocher à son président,
et il est clairement du côté de Poutine.
Le problème, c’est que
M. Bondarenko n’existe absolument pas,
c’est une création
des fermes à trolls russes.
Simplement, il n’y a pas un M. Bondarenko,
il y en a des milliers.
Ces gens ont été créés artificiellement,
les algorithmes utilisés pour ça
sont très proches de ceux-là,
même moins bons que les Stein-GAN :
sur l’image que j’aurais dû vous montrer,
qui malheureusement n’est pas là,
on voit assez facilement qu’il y a
une dissymétrie du visage
qui n’est pas normale chez l’humain,
c’est-à-dire que les oreilles
ont une formation des lobes
qui est asymétrique
et ça, à part un cas pathologique,
ça n’arrive pas.
De même, souvent,
dans ce type de technologie,
les yeux n’ont pas les formes symétriques
et c’est aussi un problème.
Là où je veux en venir,
c’est qu’il est possible
d’utiliser ces technologies
pour des choses évidemment
très, très négatives.
Ce n’est pas seulement les images,
aussi des vidéos.
Ça, c’est un exemple de vidéo
qu’on appelle un transfert de contexte.
Ça consiste à prendre une vidéo,
c’est celle de gauche
qui est la vraie ici.
Gauche, oui, c’est ça.
Donc celle en hiver.
Et on va transposer cette image
dans un contexte printanier.
Enfin, d’été même.
Cette transformation se fait
de manière mécanique et automatique.
Maintenant, on sait faire
des réseaux de neurones
qui savent apprendre un contexte
et le transposer sur un autre contexte.
J’aurais pu prendre
un exemple de deep fake
où on transpose la photo
d’une personne sur une autre
pour faire l’animer, lui faire
dire des discours, etc.
Que ce soit des images ou des vidéos,
on a atteint un niveau où on arrive
à fabriquer des choses
qui sont excessivement crédibles
à première vue.
Mais on va quand même voir
qu’on peut se protéger contre ça.
Je prends un dernier exemple vraiment
malicieux d'approche de falsification.
C’est fait avec ce qu’on appelle
une Virtual Camera.
Ça consiste à prendre,
lors d’un contrôle, comme par exemple
un contrôle d’identité à distance,
ce que vous faites
quand vous ouvrez un compte bancaire
ou lorsque vous louez
une voiture par vous-même,
vous prenez un document
et vous le scannez avec votre téléphone.
Là, vous voyez à gauche,
vous avez le scan d’origine
et à droite, vous avez un scan
transformé par Virtual Camera.
C’est-à-dire que les traits biométriques
de la photo ont été changés.
Tout en donnant l'aspect vraiment
du vrai document.
Quelqu’un peut s’emparer de l’identité
de quelqu’un d’autre grâce à ça.
Il peut transformer son identité
pour apparaître comme quelqu’un
de notre personnalité, notre identifiant,
pour être utilisé
et pour être reconnu comme tel
par des systèmes automatiques d’identité.
Le problème donc,
c’est que ces technologies
sont aujourd’hui
disponibles pour tout le monde.
Un produit comme Avatarify,
que je mentionne ici,
c’est open source,
vous le trouvez sur GitHub.
Si vous voulez vous en servir
pour transformer vos vidéos, etc,
pas en cinq minutes,
mais si vous vous intéressez
un peu à la programmation,
pas la programmation en tant que telle
mais à l’utilisation des technologies,
vous en avez pour une heure ou deux.
Les autres outils, qui sont sous forme
d’application téléphone,
sont même encore plus simples à utiliser.
Sommes-nous donc entrés
dans le millénaire de l’illusion ?
Est-ce que tout va être
complètement indétectable
et est-ce qu’on va se retrouver avec des
informations qui n’ont aucune fiabilité ?
Heureusement, l’esprit humain
s’est quand même beaucoup adapté.
Et je vais vous montrer que vous-même,
vous êtes tout à fait capables
de détecter ce genre de choses.
Ça, c’est une photo de lancement
de missiles iraniens.
Lorsqu’on regarde cette image-là,
on peut avoir une impression
d’une chose assez crédible au départ.
Et puis…
on peut constater ça.
Vous voyez ces petits nuages ici ?
Et à côté, vous avez les mêmes nuages.
Ça, c'est impossible.
Vous voyez immédiatement
que si vous avez un nuage produit
par le démarrage d’une fusée,
c’est quelque chose de
complètement chaotique,
Vous n’en aurez pas deux pareils.
C’est impossible d’avoir
deux fois la même structure.
Ce qui veut dire
qu’on peut trouver des indices
qui vont nous permettre de dire
qu’une image,
c’est quelque chose qui doit avoir
une certaine cohérence,
une certaine logique et qui doit
ne pas présenter ce type d’éléments.
En fait, vous en avez déjà l’expérience.
Quand vous regardez
les films des années 60
ou les films des années 80, même
les vieux Star Wars non retouchés,
de ces dernières années,
les versions d’origine,
les effets spéciaux sont pitoyables.
Vous les reconnaissez,
vous êtes capables d’identifier
que c’est un effet spécial
alors que ce n’était pas forcément
le cas au moment de la sortie du film.
Les premiers spectateurs
ont pu entrer dans le jeu.
En fait, on s'habitue.
On est capable de s’adapter,
de comprendre, de trouver les incohérences
et au fur et à mesure de les découvrir.
Comment faire ça au-delà
de sa propre expérience ?
Comment automatiser ça ?
Comment avoir des outils
qui vont nous permettre de dire :
« Je sais que cette photo
a été manipulée. »
et encore plus difficile :
« Je sais que cette photo
n’a pas été manipulée. »
Alors ça, c’est la photo d’origine,
juste pour vous montrer
à quoi elle correspondait.
La troisième fusée n’a pas décollé.
Eh bien, pour répondre
à la question précédente,
on n’est pas totalement désarmés.
Et quand on parle d’armes, c’est justement
grâce aux armes qu’on va s’en tirer.
En fait,
en forensique criminelle,
il existe une technique utilisée
depuis un siècle à peu près,
qui est la balistique judiciaire,
la balistique utilisée pour analyser
comment une balle est sortie d’un fusil,
comment elle a traversé des matériaux,
s’est retrouvée dans le corps de quelqu’un
et comment il s’est retrouvé
par terre par exemple.
Cette balistique, elle induit
des transformations sur la balle,
les objets, l’univers qui l’entoure,
dues à la physique
de cette transformation.
Vous connaissez l’histoire
du rainurage des armes
qui permet d’identifier par exemple
que telle balle a été tirée par tel fusil
parce que ça a laissé dans la balle
les traces du rainurage du fusil
qui sont identifiables, uniques,
qui font comme une espèce
d’empreinte digitale du fusil.
En fait, l’idée est la même
sur les images.
À l’intérieur d’une image quand une image
a été transformée, a été manipulée,
quand on a un flux d’informations
qui se produit
au fur et à mesure
de la diffusion de cette image,
les traces qu’il laisse à l’intérieur,
c’est comme le rainurage du fusil.
Ça, c'est analysable.
Ce n’est pas simple à analyser,
vous n’allez peut-être pas pouvoir
l’analyser humainement directement,
mais ça nous laisse une piste générale,
pas seulement une piste de hasard
de laisser une copie d’un élément
ou des choses comme ça, mais vraiment,
on peut être certain
que de façon régulière,
toutes les manipulations, même celles
destinées à effacer une information,
vont laisser une trace
d’une façon ou d’une autre.
Par exemple,
sur les types de manipulations
que j’évoquais tout à l’heure,
les documents d’identité
falsifiés par caméra virtuelle,
il est possible de retrouver
que les zones attaquées,
les zones qui ont été remplacées,
qu’il s’agisse du corps, du visage,
de la forme du visage
ou que ce soit le carré
de la photo en dentelle
ou d’autres éléments,
on peut les détecter par leur incohérence,
par l’incohérence statistique
de ce qui a été
dans l’image d’origine par rapport
à l’image transformée.
Et ici en particulier, à l’UTT,
on a une équipe,
l’équipe de Florent Retraint,
qui a, depuis plusieurs années,
travaillé sur ces sujets-là.
Ces sujets, ce ne sont pas les seuls,
ce ne sont pas que ces statistiques,
on a aussi d’autres mécaniques.
Par exemple, cette technique qui consiste
à aller détecter des points de similarité.
C'est un peu l'équivalent
des nuages de fumée.
Dans la partie haute de l’image,
dans toute l’image,
on essaye de détecter
quels sont les points qui se ressemblent.
Donc en haut, vous voyez des tas de points
qui sont mis en liaison
par les petites lignes,
ces petites lignes ont tous les sens,
là, c’est des hasards.
Et puis en bas, vous voyez
une grande zone.
Je remets la photo d’origine
pour que vous voyez bien.
Voilà, une grande zone
où il y a une transformation
qui est totalement cohérente.
Toutes les similarités correspondent
à la même transformation.
En fait, dans cette image,
une flèche qui était peinte
au sol a été effacée
en recopiant une partie du bitume
un peu plus loin.
Cette manipulation
est non seulement détectable,
mais on retrouve la forme des flèches
directement disponibles sur cet élément.
On trouve aussi un petit élément
qui a été manipulé en haut à gauche.
Cette image qui est là,
elle vient d’un challenge
qui a été lancé, organisé par la DGA,
la Direction Générale de l’Armement,
pour détecter automatiquement
les falsifications dans les images,
dans ce qu’on appelle
les sources ouvertes,
c’est tout ce qui est
réseaux sociaux, etc,
mais aussi les télés,
les photos de presse et autres,
toutes les images
que tout le monde peut obtenir.
Sur ces images-là,
elle a organisé un challenge
entre différentes équipes en France.
Nous avons constitué une équipe
avec Florent, avec des gens de l’URCA,
Frédéric Morain-Nicolier,
avec des gens d’Eurecom
dans le sud de la France,
Jean-Luc Dugelay,
et nous avons la chance
de remporter ce challenge,
d’avoir la meilleure précision
sur les différentes images détectées.
C’est un élément de satisfaction
pour nous dans cette collaboration.
Quand je dis « nous »,
c’est SURYS, notre société.
Ça prouve qu’il est possible
de faire ces détections,
de mettre en place des outils
pour se prémunir contre les manipulations,
les fausses circulations d’informations,
au moins au niveau
des images et des vidéos.
Et je voudrais conclure
sur une prise
de conscience générale en la matière :
à propos des effets
des outils de type deep learning
que j’ai évoqués tout à l’heure,
avec le Artificial Intelligence Act,
une proposition de règlement qui
a été sortie par la Commission européenne
l’année dernière
qui commence à proposer des approches,
en particulier des obligations
de transparence sur les manipulations,
des obligations de conformité
sur les traitements de données
et même sur l’interdiction
de certains types de traitements
qui pourraient amener
à des manipulations des humains
pouvant causer des dégâts.
Merci.